first of all I mean I mean one call from
Kevin feige changed my life forever okay
I mean you could there are a million
different first chances that you could
get whether it's like a network pilot or
like uh you know some indie movie that
you do it didn't have to be Marvel no
this is the but this is the gold
standard it's like holy [__] you know
imagine that being your first first
movie so I mean I was I I wanted to be
very proactive off the bat just you know
I went to business school and even
though I didn't pay attention for like
98 of it I still retained enough of the
knowledge to be like great to be
stagnant is death right could you have
to kind of find a way to take ownership
and I think Marvel was fantastic in
getting me that platform and um I I
truth truthfully truthfully I have
nothing but fantastic things to say
because they've been wonderful what I
will say is nobody prepares you to be
famous there's no class and and try as
someone might to design that class
if they haven't been through it
themselves they'll have no [__] idea
what all of that life entails what it
means to lose the ability to have just a
person-to-person conversation out on the
street because now when you step out
it's different it's different people see
you but they don't really see you they
see you're you're the thing it's like
you you become you become a virgin and
and you know what I say this all the
time I mean rightfully so right there's
a gift and a curse attached to anything
great there's so much that goes with
that so when you say you're not prepared
or nobody can prepare you you're you're
absolutely right and the crazy part is
it's just the beginning of it for you
like this is the crazy part like if you
if we were talking to the untalented guy
well then it's different and we're
talking to the guy here that's not
charismatic we're talking to a guy here
that can't hold the conversation or the
guy that I'm pulling teeth from during
the course of an interview well this is
different it's gonna be a short road for
you buddy good luck but we're not
talking to that guy like we're talking
to a guy that wants more and the more
you want well the more success and the
more Fame that comes with that so you
know what is your attitude towards more
faith towards more success
I mean I mean I feel like I still retain
so much of what my parents put in me the
the need to create stability right and
and to me
whether it's Fame I mean I don't want to
say Fame necessarily but but I mean to a
degree that's that's necessary in this
system it's necessary to be like who you
know who are the people that could green
light a project you know and am I going
to be waiting forever or or you know you
know
waiting forever for the right
opportunity to come or am I going to be
the type of person who can take
ownership and to you know participate in
the projects that he wants on his terms
so that's always been what I want and it
feels like at least right now that that
that this idea of Fame is tied in with
this idea of success you have to do that
at the same time see people [__] up
because people wait right people wait
until they're done the the hot run to go
okay now I want to try this but if you
figure out a way to do it at the same
time all right I'm rolling we're
developing part two while we're
developing part two I'm going to start
to sit with some people that I met I
want to develop a thing that I want to
do hopefully by time we're done shooting
part two while we're in pre-production
for part two I want to take the meetings
with the talent with the Personnel
producers that I had the access to
because of what I'm doing for part two
they're going to sit down with me
because of that access they're going to
not only take the meetings they're going
to give me the time and attention I can
secure these deals secure these things
so that as soon as this is wrapped up
I'm right into the next thing oh yeah
I've always been before a project in the
middle of a project at the end of the
project start the new project oh yeah I
never wait so I've I've always kept that
train moving now granted the gift in the
curse comes with well you're working all
the [__] time and you look up and you
ain't taking time to really access
what's going on or love the ones
probably your parents to be a human
being yeah that's that's a that's a
battle that I still you know have with
me I understand that I'm still going
through but for that thing that you're
talking about you have to access those
relationships while they're accessible
don't wait till they're not there oh
yeah because then those relationships go
away that door is shut when that door is
shut you're gonna look back like what
the [__] I was just the guy I seen it
happen I was just a guy I was just on
the poster they said we're not doing
part three so what are we doing with the
world is fast the world is fast you can
have a moment but it's a flat without
anything to follow it up it's a flash in
the pan and then they're on to squid
game they're under whatever the next
thing is you know
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign